so the brother asked the question about
apostasy yeah so the punishment for
apostasy in Islam so I think a lot of
time we ask this question what is the
punishment for apostasy in Islam and a
more interesting question for me
recently has been to what extent can
liberalism or does liberalism or do
liberal philosophers talk about this
because that's like that's for me a
really interesting discussion in it the
argument goes as followers right you say
that look everyone should have freedom
of belief it's a human it's an
individual human right and therefore if
someone changes their religion they
should be free to do so based on human
rights and based on the fact that they
should have freedom of consciousness and
so the argument is not a bad one because
actually coincides with the Islamic
understanding of free will and actually
it coincides with the version of Quran
which says like Rajas with Dean tucked
away in a rush to Delhi in chapter 2
verse 256 of the Quran which there is no
compulsion of religion that truth has
been made clear from falsehood so the
the idea that there should be freedom of
consciousness and freedom of belief is
actually a principle part of the Islamic
discourse because we believe that there
are two things that's here which is free
will and there's determinism over
Lazcano Taliban he writes things etc so
we believe everyone does have a right to
believe in whatever they want to believe
and the idea is not one-off and this
should be very much stressed in Islamic
discourse it's not one of individual
belief
this is to do with social contracts okay
now this is a big term in political
science what do you mean by the term
social contract now in liberal
philosophy there are two things right
there's the primacy of individual and
their right to do whatever they want
without intervention from the government
and on the other hand you have the
universality of law you're stuck between
two things as a liberal you have the
primacy of being an individual you're an
individual right you have the freedom to
do everyone and for a liberal expression
a libertarian they'll say you should the
government should keep away from putting
obstacles in the way of the individual
so that it can be as free as possible
right but then obviously they realize
almost all liberal theorists realize the
need for number one representation and
number two law which is why they have
social contract now what is social
contract social contract is number one
is forced upon us so by virtue of the
fact that I'm a British citizen you're
British isn't as well your British is
now we're gonna have to check on that
okay by virtue of the fact that we're
British citizens we have to abide by
British law and that's not something we
have any say on because of the
citizenship that we carry in other words
we're forced into a social contract it's
not a social contract which is a
voluntary or something I have any choice
in write the terms of that social
contract indicate that I have to follow
the law of this country isn't it okay so
almost all liberal theorists agreed with
this now the question is not one of
personal belief I can believe whatever I
want to believe from a liberal
perspective and from an Islamic
perspective and not not have any
punishment in any context exerted on me
in any way because belief is something
which is personal belief is something
which is between me and God and it's
only known through the publication of
that belief or profession of that belief
in public settings right so in other
words people won't know I believe unless
I don't declare it
question to what extent are what are
referred to as laws of apostasy which is
for example if I come out and say I'm no
longer say for instance a Christian I'm
not going to use the Muslim example say
it's a Christian country and I come out
and say I'm no longer a Christian to
what extent can social contract theory
the lack of which were which was
advocated by people like Rousseau and
obviously John Locke before him Thomas
Hobbes and almost all liberal theorists
even Jay s mill can it facilitate for a
kind of punitive punishment for those
who renounce their faith publicly now
I'm gonna make a very bold claim here
I'm putting a slam to the side right now
I'm putting a sum to the side it's not
about Islam I'm gonna say that from my
reading of liberalism that that can be
facilitated what am I talking about I am
saying quite clearly that if someone
comes in a liberal state which also
claims to be for instance Christian
which can happen according to Jay's mill
that number one point one that in that
liberal state it would be it could be
seen as a rupturing of the social
contract if someone professes publicly
yes that they are not X faith anymore
that is if that faith is connected with
the social contract
why is your evidence for this I will
give you the evidence for this right now
John Locke wrote a book obviously
everyone knows it called the two
treatises of government I think he wrote
this in 1687 when he also wrote I wrote
a book called on tolerance in chapter 19
of this book in chapter 19 of this book
on tolerance he talks about Jewish
States John Locke talks about Jewish
states and up if it's not chapter 19 is
somewhere in the book and he says it's
legitimate to allow Jewish people to
implement Mosaic law and we know full
well that in Mosaic law there are laws
of apostasy and he continues by talking
about the social exclusion of a certain
amount of certain people of different
faith groups he talks about Mohammedans
and atheists now Muslims wouldn't say
this by the way so in essence you could
argue that Islam applies a more rigorous
type of liberalism than John Locke
himself why because Islam says in us in
an Islamic state or some a governance if
you're a Muslim or a Christian or a Jew
you can live in your respective
province without harm now someone will
say but then they say that you have to
pay the jizya but according to the
hadith
jizya is one dinner so it's a tax it's a
tax that almost everyone has to pay for
the protection of the people one dinner
is less than there's a cat which is
usually typically 20 dinars of my Saab
so therefore the jizya is less so this
idea this false notion of GCR being a
discriminatory tax it's only
discriminatory against Muslims because
Muslims have to pay more by the way if
you want to call it discriminatory
Muslims actually have to pay more as a
cat's yeah so going back to I was saying
about apostasy I came across in my new
campus work and I also came across John
Stuart Mill's work and there was a
manuscript that was attributed to John
Stuart Mill which actually specifically
talks about blasphemy law and he talks
about blasphemy law and he says John
Stuart Mill says
Joshua mill actually says equivocally
that if killing someone this is John
Stuart Mill not the Prophet Muhammad not
Moses not Jesus it's not a medieval text
this is one of the prime figures of
liberalism in the Victorian era in
Britain by which and through which most
other subsequent theories take their
liberalism from he actually says in that
manuscript that killed them yes
he says kill them kill them if you have
to kill many of them kill them in other
words it seems to me an Immanuel Kant
has some similar sayings it seems to me
that the question we should be asking is
not whether Islam allows apostasy law
it's where the liberalism allows
apostasy law because actually when we
look at the primary source materials of
the most regarded liberal theorists the
highest founding fathers of liberalism
it would seem that a social contract
theory could in fact facilitate of a
kind of apostasy law right - that's from
a liberal perspective Aslam is something
quite similar in many ways but has some
fundamental differences
so relatable ooh a man who's one of the
prophets companions you had a list of
people who are munafa corn and those
list of people were people who had
rejected Islam there were not Muslims
the Quran says in Delhi would have
Athena Fidel kill s Philemon enough that
certainly the the hypocrites are in the
lowest part pit of the Hellfire they are
not Muslims they are not believers they
are not movements yes yet
there was no apostasy punishment applied
to those individuals there was no
apostasy pub thing applied to them why
because it regarded to personal belief
so I'll because I'll be unequivocal in
saying this that which regards to
personal belief is that is different
from that which is expressed publicly
and thereby from a liberal perspective
before even becomes an Islamic one
ruptures the social contract now the
question is is it fair and is it okay is
it possible is it conceivable in a
liberal state bearing in mind social
contract theory to have these laws and
therefore can liberalism can a liberal
state slip into a kind of nationalistic
stay intolerant state the answer is
unfortunately yes that is the elasticity
of liberalism liberalism because of the
tensions between the primacy of
individual versus the universality of
law could sway in either one of the two
directions could either become very much
libertarian in the sense that you know
we don't even allow I mean think about
this this way yeah libertarians would
argue why do we have seatbelt laws yeah
we have Seaborg known you have to go in
your car you have to put on a seatbelt
don't you but why do I have the policy
bro why is they a libertarian would
argue this is a paternalism they'll say
it's like the state is acting as your
parent now put under what it's not to
live even if I hurt myself it's none of
your business if I help myself someone
could argue a libertarian would
definitely argue but even if I hurt
myself in the car tonight I create a
crater crash it's not I'm not harming
anyone else by doing this why are you
telling me what to do so I'm allowed to
drink alcohol think
this because this is the this is the
ignorant of some people of their own
philosophy right I'm allowed to drink
alcohol yeah and in some places smoke
weed and have you know unlimited amount
of sexual partners polyandry and that
could cause problems for myself sexual
problems all of that is permissible but
I have to put on a seatbelt
I mean does that sound reasonable to you
seriously think about it I'm allowed to
compete in mixed martial arts well I
could injure someone and and die I can
go to a complainer I could be but I have
to put on the the seatbelt what kind of
nonsense is this
think about it it doesn't make any sense
let's be honest about this yeah why are
why is the state telling us you have to
put on the seat belt if I if I don't put
on the seat belt well I harm anyone else
think about it am I gonna harm any I'll
have myself yes but I'm not going to
harm anyone else by not putting my see
boy yeah boy if I hit the no no my point
is this my point is that liberal
philosophy can go in two different ways
yeah you have on the left side let's say
for the sake of argument and extreme
libertarianism where we don't want the
state to get involved in any matter yeah
like for example we shouldn't have
seatbelt laws that's one side on the
other side is where liberal philosophers
will say actually there should be
restriction and that should be enforced
through the context of social contract
theory into the universality of law
which should be applicable on the
individual laws should be applied and
John Stuart Mill's has something very
interesting you know he says he says for
instance he goes if a husband and wife
they have sex in public is that harming
anyone else you could argue no you could
argue no not physically harming anyone
if for example not to point anyone out
someone brings his wife and you know in
the park in the middle here sorry to say
has sexual it takes his trousers off
yeah and all of those things sorry to
say Annie is that going to harm anyone
no they're having sex you can decide to
leave you can go you don't have to look
at it you can't you don't need to be
offended by it what why is that censor
yes you could argue this yep now I
understand children and all that but we
can have an area where they can do it no
problem you can have an adult park why
not right Colin yeah I'm just I'm just
yeah I agree with you I agree with this
point I'm not telling you should I do
deal for us yes yes my friend I agree
with you yes but I'm saying
so John Stuart Mill said look there's
some things this is what he said there's
some things which keys our sensibilities
we have a culture and that's not
acceptable in our culture and he says
therefore the universality of law and
the social contract should put
restriction so here John Stuart Mill is
talking about in on Liberty in his book
he's saying that there are certain
things which should not be accessible
for people
ie having sex with your wife in public
spheres or your husband yes so the
question is now is Israel question what
should be allowed to be done in publicly
without fear of reprisal or other or
otherwise a fear of a consequence from
the law this is a thing that liberals
struggle with that's why you have
different schools of thought within
liberalism and I've something about
elasticity of liberalism yeah it's not
something which all can be liberal now
now the question is when they come to us
this is what I'm going to say to
everyone to answer your question sorry
yeah when they come to us and say look
you need to modernize what did I say you
say you need to modernize Muslims you
know you need to modernize what do you
mean come on tell me white man what do
you mean by well yeah what do you mean
by modernize I want to know what you
mean yeah okay you'll say look I'm by
the way gonna say white man I'm not
talking about you know I'm talking yeah
yeah the Western man what do you mean
what do you mean by it all right I tell
you what you mean
you mean become more liberal because
that is the dominant ethnic in the
Western world yes
okay now I'm liberal I have embraced
liberalism brother today I mean okay
what do we do let's go look at the
liberal books
let's look at the works of John Locke
and John Stuart Mill and Rousseau bottom
I'm not an ambassador for Saudi Arabia
yes I agree with you all I I don't yeah
yeah I agree with this point yeah I do
it that way yeah yeah sorry come back
I'm a liberal now yeah so yes I've
embraced liberalism let's go to the
books of the Liberals so we find within
the books of the Liberals you haven't
you have a spectrum of understanding of
to what the question the main question
is to what extent should the government
intervene and you don't have one answer
for that you have ten answers from ten
different liberal thinkers yes and so
here's what I'm saying to you is that
going back to apostasy law yeah gone
back to apostasy look I'll come to our
speaker after cuz I can yes I agree I
agree with you brother yes yes yes you
have to have rules yes that's that's my
that's my argument I agree with you yes
I do with you
yeah the man made a good point there you
must have rules otherwise people who
behaves anarchy he's right but the
question is just yeah think about it
think have you ever thought about this
before
they talk about human rights so to watch
that kind of liberal state institutional
institutionalize the law universalize it
and apply a death penalty for those who
don't go against it
well according to John Locke according
to John Stuart Mill according to your
manual can according to John Russo Russo
according to most even Voltaire I
believe as well
according to almost every liberal they
have full right to do that because of
the social contract therefore don't tell
me about liberalism I mean that's what
that's the issue here they come with a
false pretense they're even know their
own philosophy that's the issue they
don't even know their own philosophy
that's why America gets away with panel
of death penalties they have a death
penalty in America it's not against
liberalism to have a death penalty it's
not against it
yes sir yes sir yes sir that's a
political question if you're asking
about Parliament obviously going back to
charles ii and his but we don't want to
go in this country there's a whole
there's a whole tradition and if you
want to go back to william ii will name
the first William the Conqueror in 1066
I don't know how far back you want to
take this we can talk after I say it's a
long when I go and go Vesely we should I
go back to the room but at newman's I
don't know I don't know
so here ladies and gentlemen don't be
deceived as my as my is my point when
you ask her and this is the
presupposition which we have to
investigate because when they say human
rights what do they what do they
actually mean they mean 1948 convention
of human rights that was put in place
after World War two that's what they
that's what they mean right all right so
that convention if you read it it's got
30 articles
it's got 30 different points 30
different points in everyone in those 30
different points you have the right of
this the right of that the right of this
right now
here's my criticism of the whole thing
I've got a criticism of the whole I've
got a criticism of the whole thing I've
got criticism you know when you tell
someone you've got a right to do
something if I tell you brother you have
the right to do this you know you know
what is telling you to do to be entitled
that's what it's telling you to be right
so it's it's a negative way of asserting
something it's a look you have this
right it means you are entitled to this
the question is why does this why does
the UN Declaration of Human Rights 1948
not have anything on responsibilities
because by telling you how to write is
telling you what you deserve but it's
not telling you what you need to do and
that's the problem with a lot of the
rights culture that we have any moment
you have the right to this yeah the
right slap you have the children a child
has a right to education but a teacher
does not have a right to a
responsibility to teach how does that
even work
you need to counterbalance rights with
responsibilities that's that is a
communitarian criticism which has been
made of liberal human rights culture
look I want to wrap up by saying yes I
want to wrap up by saying in the in the
context of the West we don't believe in
if someone changes their religion yes
whatever it is well hi you're there we
don't care if they're Muslim we don't we
don't look good even in the context
although Islamic state we don't care
about personal beliefs the extent to
which we care about personal beliefs is
the extent to which it's connected with
concepts of rupturing a pre-existing
social contract which is put in place
with the permission yes of that
individual because they have to obey act
they have to pledge allegiance they have
to give legitimate is a legitimacy of
that state
so in some I would say the laws the
punitive laws of Islam and this is my
final statement my final statement every
single punitive law in Islam the death
penalty is what they call the rid the
punishment every single one of them can
be justified not Islamic lean through
liberalism and through the social
contract
yes we would be going away from
libertarianism but you can justify it
through the universality of law so it's
not even a liberal critique of Islam if
we're honest with ourselves and
therefore it has no moral or ethical
basis it's just a subjective Mally a
value judgment of 21st century
complexity
Duprey